l'été 2022 a été le plus chaud jamais
enregistré en Europe un record qui
deviendra bientôt la norme
[Musique]
dans certains endroits du globe les
travailleurs sont déjà confrontés à des
températures humides et qui frôlent les
limites du corps humain
au rythme actuel du réchauffement ce
seuil pourrait être même dépassé d'ici
les 50 prochaines années
[Musique]
elle est essentielle ramener le système
à l'équilibre en 2030 or le déficit ne
disparaîtra pas selon le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites il devrait
se dégrader à moins 0,2% du PIB soit au
moins 5 milliards d'euros pourtant ce
matin Bruno Le Maire dans des morts pas
grâce à nos décisions nous ne sommes pas
dans une impasse il y aura un sujet de
financement mais beaucoup moins
important que ce qu'il aurait été
plusieurs années de suite la courbe des
décès a suivi quasiment à l'identique
celle de la température au fil des
saisons
plus le mercure est monté plus nombreux
ont été les décès
chaque année l'hiver a offert un répit
aux ouvriers mais à chaque printemps le
nombre de morts est reparti à la hausse
[Musique]
pas prendre l'avion ne prennent pas
l'avion et ceux qui ont envie de prendre
l'avion comme moi prennent l'avion parce
que j'ai encore envie d'aller à New York
par exemple voilà voilà parce que ça
fait longtemps que je fais dehors Israël
j'ai envie d'aller en Terre sainte géant
un jour je veux pas mourir avant d'avoir
mourir je veux voir le
macho mourir
retiens bien cette leçon
[Musique]
une course contre la montre qui rend les
livreurs sourds de leur corps
cet employé du PS en Arizona filmé par
la caméra de surveillance d'un client
montre tous les signes d'un coup de
chaud
bien que Chanel il n'oublie pas de
marquer son passage avant de repartir à
son véhicule
il faut que tu respires
et ça c'est rien de dire
ensuite je trouve ça d'un niveau
d'incivilité c'est-à-dire tu en as rien
à faire des autres oui c'est tout
qui sont pas du tout cohérents c'est
tout vous bloquez vous bloquez les
tunnels il y aura des trains le jour
vous serez cohérents
des maraîchers
vous me connaissez un peu parce qu'elle
vous devinez ce que je vais faire dans
les jours qui arrivent voilà
je ne pourrais pas rester dans ce
journal c'est impossible
et ce sera j'imagine pour vous
une décision difficile à prendre
France Inter et peut-être à la gauche
que c'est news étaient à droite voilà
on est tous extrêmement attaché à ce
journal quand on lui a donné beaucoup de
choses effectivement on a fait
énormément de rencontres avec les
lecteurs les lecteurs nous ont fait
confiance je pense que vous connaissez
ça parce qu'on entend beaucoup ça sur
cnews aussi croiser lecteurs qui nous
remercient d'exister tout simplement en
fait de de les laisser respirer de dire
autre chose et c'est précisément sur
cette autre chose que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec certains dans la direction
et c'est bien au-dessus de la direction
aujourd'hui c'est étude duel de nid qui
prend les reines et c'est vraiment pas
lui mon sujet sur le perron une femme de
73 ans et sa petite fille de 7 ans un
homme s'approche d'elle puis soudain
bloque la porte son gouffre et extirp
violemment femme et enfant qui tombe
peut-être la première sur le trottoir
l'agresseur écarte ensuite la petite
fille violemment pour ramasser un objet
puis une bouteille d'eau avant de
s'enfuir très vite sur les réseaux
sociaux Marine Le Pen parle d'agression
quotidienne et d'une insécurité aggravée
par le chaos migratoire même si l'homme
est français le maire de Bordeaux
écologiste regrette ses polémiques
je n'entends pas commenter des réactions
qui
non seulement sont indécentes
mais sont indignes il y a 80% des
cyclistes 70 à 80% qui ne respect pas le
code de la route
moi je tourne en général sur un rayon de
30 40 km
essence interdit dans n'importe quel
sens la personne qui a autorisé la loi
selon laquelle l'excite de prendre
l'essence interdit on devrait la peindre
un mur mais c'est un scandale le code de
la route doit être universelle pour tout
le monde
près d'un an avant les JO de Paris des
perquisitions étaient menées aujourd'hui
au siège du comité d'organisation et sur
plusieurs sites des enquêtes
préliminaires ont en effet été ouverte
pour des prises illégales d'intérêt
détournement de fonds publics et
favoritisme cela concerne l'attribution
de marché pour la réalisation de travaux
pour vous Ariane c'est synonyme de yanos
quand on commence à bouillir c'est chaud
là oui ce soir le comité d'organisation
des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
confirme avoir été perquisitionné nous
collaborons activement avec les
enquêteurs pour faciliter les
investigations pour assurer la
transparence et la régularité de
centaines de marchés Paris 2024 c'est
doté de procédures exigeantes et a mis
en place un comité d'éthique et un
comité d'audit pour superviser son
activité une volonté de transparence
mais une image écornée à 400 jours du
début des JO c'est un coup de pied
presque divin qui cumulent plus de 3
millions de vues sur Twitter alors qu'il
participe à un défi lancé à la mi-temps
d'un match de football entre San Rosset
et Portland se supportèrent des
earthwake à propulser le ballon si
minutieusement qu'il a atterri en plein
dans le mille un geste exceptionnel
depuis la surface de réparation à plus
de 40 mètres de la cible alors les
internautes espèrent pour lui le gros
lot un million de dollars un abonnement
exclusif au club ou même un recrutement
dans l'équipe